il n'était pas au courant de la surprise
pour son centième anniversaire
un retour à ses premières amours un vol
en planeur à a écrit que ses pilotes à
bala j'ignore le nom du pilote mais il
ya il va y avoir un pilote c'est gaston
points n'a jamais passé son permis mais
il a son brevet depuis l'âge de 17 ans
son diplôme est datée de 1938
est ce que vous êtes bien ses enfants
petits enfants arrière petits enfants
tous unis sur le tarmac et le voilà qui
décolle le pilote raconte à la radio que
ça bavarde la nouvelle dynamique en fait
ici là on est en thermique le vol
thermique c'est qu'on va utiliser les
thermiques pour pouvoir grande remontée
comme ça
le vol dynamique c'est lorsque c'est le
vent qui sans même 20 minutes à barboter
au milieu des nuages et le voilà en
pleine forme
un cadeau c'était cadeau merci c'est
super et c'est bien tant mieux tant
mieux
voilà pour retrouver sa jeunesse ah oui
elle s'est envolée à genève mais tu l'a
rattrapé il n'ya plus qu'à trouver
encore mieux pour les 101 ans de gaston